cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
ladies and gentlemen we've got some
schadenfreude for you
from the Oregon uh from Oregon live Nike
to permanently close northeast Portland
Factory Store why because Nike went to
the city and said we need cops and the
city said no we're sorry you're dealing
with safety challenges let me see if I
can find this it's a really here we go
look at this
wait mayor Ted wheeler said he was very
disappointed with the news of Nike's
community store closure and that his
team in city had worked tirelessly
tirelessly and in good faith with Nike
for almost a year to offer Creative
Solutions to their safety challenges
that's what they call it when mobs raid
your store when far left extremists set
fire to property all around your city
over whenever someone's safety Channel
says they're doing something in good
faith that makes me feel like it's it's
it's full of it like that they're full
like they're just making that up you
don't need to tell me it's in good faith
if you tell me that it's like your your
virtue signaling and it's not really in
good faith this is yeah this is one of
many stores that has been leaving
Portland
um Andy know who's with post-millennial
it keeps reporting on this because he's
been he's been writing about this for
years what's going on with antifa and
the militants and like the horrible
people who just want to destroy Portland
and this one we got the story for the
Post Yeah I just pulled this up on my
phone we're gonna we're gonna lay it
Katie worked on this yeah multi-layered
shot in freuda a guy who said quote
please smash all my windows if it will
be a step toward change has announced
that he must shut down his Tap Room wait
do you see the quote where he says we
were successful in every way except
financially
[Laughter]
so this is a leftist Portland business
whose owner advocated for the city's
destruction announces closing his tap
room after suffering significant
financial losses since that time the
owner of Reverend's Net's Hard Cider on
Southeast 35th Division Street
identifies as he him on social media
thanks Andy and he's always very good
pronouns he's permanently shuttering the
doors to his Tap Room the taproom's
beverages are are a former Staple in the
Progressive City now struggling with
surging crime homicides and business
closures following the Summer of Love
that's what Jenny Durkin called it the
mayor of Seattle at the time the summer
yeah she's in the Summer of Love that's
right what a where did he say that
we succeeded everywhere but financially
it's in there I know because I I
reviewed the story
it's in there somewhere nope why is what
happened to it
it's a great quote if it's real oh there
it is there it is but we've done so many
things and made thousands of ciders we
were successful in every way but
Financial there it is
your business I would assume but I guess
not for everybody well it is apparently
because he's closing his business he has
now failed to make to keep his business
open dude because he failed financially
uh business is fake business is fail
okay I'm not I don't want to rag on
someone smash all my windows if it will
be a step toward change that's what I'm
saying I'm not going to rag on someone
because they went out of business right
businesses fail all the time it's sad
people try they don't make it but my
dude you advocated for your business to
fail I'm proud of you and I want to say
I congratulate you on your success yes
yes change was made right indeed not at
the cash rate yes if if he said that
smashing out his windows will make a
step toward change he got exactly what
he wanted so he was right he succeeded
did he thinks
through his window and then come in and
be like thank you so much I'll buy a
beer like whatever he that he sells
people always so ridiculous that's what
people always think they always think
like oh I'm I'm on board with you so you
will spare me and there have been a
number of stories that we've reported on
of like far leftists who have small
businesses who advocate for BLM and
antifa and then are surprised when like
I think one woman got killed in a in a
robbery and her family was like no but
we she wouldn't want anyone to go to
prison for this and it's like they
literally killed the woman remember
remember the comic from Shen where he
was like my bike got stolen but I
imagine the guy who stole it is happier
to have it than I am to lose it so the
world so total happiness and crazy it's
like ridiculous that guy who stole your
bike didn't think twice about it and
hooked it for 20 bucks he's not happy at
all he doesn't care he's maybe high now
so maybe he's happy there's this NPR
story from a while ago where they said
some businesses in Portland OR different
cities would hang like black lives
matter stuff in in Hope Seattle would
too during the chat thing in hopes of
like not not being attacked or not
losing their business and it was not a
guarantee they were just needing to
Signal it even if they didn't believe it
uh I mean this guy is such a character I
wonder what he'll do next I find it
interesting uh because there's no end
goal for him now right like you had a
business it got destroyed so now if you
thought your business was serving your
community it's gone and also you don't
have a way to make money so why would
you go to this length to try and appeal
to a mob that doesn't care about you um
I'm thinking about Nike still and Nike
at one point earlier this year offered
to pay police themselves to protect
theirs that's right that was in the
story and Portland was like oh you can't
actually power please we don't have
enough of them we don't have enough and
also you can't do that we don't want you
to we defunded our police and now not
only do our police have less budget but
no one wants to be one because that was
the way the defund the police movement
was so successful is no one wants to be
a cop now so there's a lot of
resignations
and no one wants to join us I want to
read some of this from the story one
tweet said is quote please know whose
Windows you're breaking such a bad take
though I think there's a distinction to
be made between removing statues and
breaking windows at a museum or am I
missing some perspective
cider man says just because you're doing
a better job now than you've done in the
past doesn't exclude you from a little
bit of Reckoning doesn't demand it
either but windows are windows no my
friend windows are a symbol of our
security and safety and prosperity
because before you would have walls and
when we started putting up thin windows
that could be shattered with a rock
sitting right in front of it that was a
sign that we were honorable and secure
and we were not concerned that you could
easily make your way into my building
and steal everything I own there are
there are coffee at Starbucks for
instance yo come on Starbucks windows I
don't know I don't know maybe Starbucks
buys bulletproof windows but most
windows are easily broken and that means
we shifted as a society towards lowering
our security to a great degree because
we trust each other and we function
together and these people exploit our
Goodwill with death and destruction and
they says windows or windows then let's
go back to putting up walls windowless
stores how about that brick not just
that but like with the with the little
with the little slits so that we can
shoot out at them little panels for
self-defense yeah like they did with the
castles
yeah
the murder holes yeah but only only in
self-defense and in extreme cases where
you're under threat if you vote for the
right people if you vote for the arrow
slits I think yeah that's what I was
thinking of this feels like when you
when you like qualify with a mob and
when you like justify mob tactics and
buy silent mob tactics it's like um
someone that's like oh like Grizzly
manage you ever see that movie where
he's like yeah it's a bear just don't
worry about it I know how to love it
it'll be different this time and then
the bear turns and eats him of course
the bear is gonna eat you I didn't get
too graphic about how he was devoured
but it wasn't face first it was from the
other direction oh so he was like alive
being consumed yes usually that's how
bears and wolves do it each alive why
don't they go for the soft bits first
like the eyes they go for the butthole
first oh good gravy what a weird
pathetic wolves wolves 100 I I imagine
that's true yeah that's what Rogan told
me Joe Rogan said that he isn't a
wildlife expert
but like you can't I mean you trust
dirty divisive untrustworthy and violent
mob tactics I don't trust Bears or
Wolves yeah to be like trusting a wild
animal kind of mobs ain't trustworthy
she didn't trust anyone no and they
don't care like they don't that's what I
care about your little middle class
lifestyle where you want to advocate for
everybody to be yeah wild predators try
to eat the butthole first
there's so much flavor soft I guess I
guess it is right into the colon where
there's like partially digestive food
and stuff yikes and then they go just
all the way up yeah
no I can't wild I don't want to imagine
that well this guy's building is being
this guy's off he got eaten by the
butthole okay his business is being
devoured butthole first yeah he like
took his pants off and bent over for
them and he was like yes please yeah do
you like mice
put like some hot sauce on it he was
like no no it's good because if I if I
offer to you guys won't do this to me I
mean this is like the strangest part of
virtue signal culture at all which is
like if I virtue single heart if I tell
you that I'm on your side enough nothing
bad will happen to me because I'm on the
right side of history and that's not the
case at all I hope this lesson is taken
that if you diminish law enforcement in
your area that will slowly deplete the
economic value of your area and then
your business if your business it will
slowly and then very quickly deplete the
entire area it's like nobody studied the
French Revolution no you know like
doesn't doesn't everyone know like you
can't control the mob it doesn't matter
how much you say they're on that you're
on their side like oh we don't like the
king either okay well your head's going
in the basket too have fun with that
people you would think that people would
know that stuff but they don't I went to
school in the United States and a lot of
kids just didn't pay attention
in 2020 they were telling me I didn't
know anything about history but it's
like you didn't pay attention to
anything in history classic I know you
didn't but no I was there I watched you
yes stupider and stupider yeah so uh cat
feline Predators Lions
they they don't eat the stomachs go for
the liver because the stomachs contain
vegetation they can't digest so they
discard it and then uh they go through
this through the gut yeah but but yeah a
lot of animals like uh wolves and and
vultures will go through the butt
because they can pull out your guts
ow
yeah well that's good but thanks for
that one Ian yeah I feel like I did
learn something really nice though I'm
actually glad you told me that I haven't
seen Grizzly Man yet Werner Herzog told
Grizzly man's mom not to watch it oh you
know the story yeah I know the story
well and that's why I've never seen the
film The guy and his girlfriend spent
time with the woods with the Bears and
then eventually when the camera was on
but the lens cap was covering it you
hear them both get devoured in real time
screaming and him being like help me oh
this guy's awful oh yeah the guy who was
living with the Bears right yeah that's
what his girlfriend go around living
with Bears I mean there's a reason that
we live in little towns and the bears
live over there in the woods and when
the Bears come down the street like a
bear came down my street the other day
and I heard about it and I was like I'm
glad I was in the house yeah they can
have my trash I'm staying over here in
the house we went to the Outer Banks
yeah North Carolina and there's an area
where you can go to see alligators and
turtles and bears it was really cool we
saw turtles that were like this big like
30 year old Turtles a snap Snapper was
probably 30 years old but then we saw
two black bears and uh one of them was
20 feet from the car from the road
people pull their cars over I just got
it and started taking pictures they're
like professional professional nature
photographers and this black bear
massive like wow like it it's big I've
seen black bears you know you know all
over the place this guy was massive and
he was chilling walking real slow and
then stopped and just sat for about 10
feet from a line of cars and just
watched him I posted a picture and I was
like bear seems fake AF like it it
seriously looked like a guy in a suit
like two guys in a suit like that zoo in
China
for real no I don't know I'm not gonna
accuse him of anything it was a real
bear though that the thing yeah I
remember going to Great Adventure Safari
in New Jersey and uh I was driving
around with my mom and I said I was
little and I was like Mom what are those
kangaroos doing and she was like oh my
god look away
try to jump over here I used to walk
through my yard that's when I like when
I was in high school and stuff and there
was one like it was very weird because
you would see the bear and cubs one year
and then next year the Cubs were
slightly bigger and I have much younger
siblings so we used to like have to send
them out with air horns to play in the
yard because you just don't know when
the Bears are going to be there and
they're not going to be there I gotta
but you can't just keep kids inside all
day when I was in sixth grade thank you
that was my real upbringing yeah I was
in sixth grade we went on a field trip I
can't remember which zoo we went to it
was one of the ones in Chicago and uh we
went to look at the baboons
and the bad one of the baboons okay wait
earmuffs
for parents yeah you don't want your
kids to listen I mean it's not that it's
not that it's not that gross it's gross
though but I don't think it's that
inappropriate but anyway one of the
baboons is just sitting there and we're
all looking over the edge and then the
baboon shoves his fingers up his ass and
pulls out you know dang matter and then
looks at it sniffs his hand and then
smears it on the ground and all the kids
are watching my teacher freaks I was
like Dad don't look don't look it's like
we've seen it all you can't it's too
late she was like if one of you does
class I don't
know yeah it was funny baboons are gross
are the baboons with the rainbow butts
yeah
I don't like those guys what's up with
that yeah they're they don't want to
mess with that they're just one uncanny
you know why baboon rainbow butt have
you seen the video where there was like
uh during covid there's no tourists so
there's no food and then someone threw
like a Snickers bar and then all of them
like run go for it it's crazy yeah you
don't mean nobody was feeding them
well so like normally there are tourists
throwing things that eat the garbage
with no tourists there's no food right
and that's also why like the rats came
out in New York City they were
everywhere oh yeah just like huge groups
running around because they were like
there's no food anymore we better go
find it crazy you better go attack
people I've seen some creepy rats in New
York rats are creepy in New York
remember Pizza rat that was real Pizza
rat yeah what was that you like found a
slice of pizza on the subway
yeah yeah you just needed a snack you
guys are so mean to him I saw I saw a
squirrel doing that once it was awesome
it was just holding a huge slice of
pizza and I was like yeah I saw a tick
tock or a seagull going into a whole
food yeah pulling a sandwich out of it
okay and then it waits for the doors and
then someone tries to run up to it for
it but then afterwards someone else is
like no you shouldn't have a sandwich
and it's like dude leave me alone but if
you're a seagull and you know how to
steal a sandwich from Whole Foods that's
your sandwich there's a video of a
seagull walking there's like a grocery
store with a like a bodega and the doors
open and the seagull walks in grabs a
bag of chicks chips and walks out
probably because the seagull recognized
the bag saw it on the ground sure saw
the food in it saw it and they're like
hey that's where it is the seagull
probably wasn't thinking I'm stealing
the sequel was thinking like oh look
another bag
currency right it was just literally
food it's just operating in the system
that he thinks we have created for it
the elephants figured out did you see
the video of the elephant eating
stopping the the car that's driving with
all the sugar cane on it and it like
walks out on the road and blocks it and
then grabs sugarcane off the truck the
videos are really smart yeah the videos
of bears breaking into houses and they
like open the fridge and look around
like they know you have something in
there oh yeah but not stealing you can't
charge them no you can't arrest a bear
first off the Optics would be awful one
of the one of the cruel uh realities of
of life is that you can't cuddle with a
bear right yeah because you look at them
and you're like it's like a gigantic dog
just fluffy but it will kill you yeah
very easily it's like it's like it's a
little eat your butt yeah it's like a
poisoned Berry it's like you want to eat
like so good but you can't yeah
delicious mushrooms well that's another
one of those movies remember that guy
who like was in Alaska it was another
sort of into the wild into the wild yeah
they ate the wrong berries and they
found them way later Emil Hirsch yeah
yeah but now with them
I think so there's a mechanical there's
uh there's an app called picture this
that you can scan a plant and I'll tell
you what it is that's smart I was
thinking the last few days about how
horrible it would be to be killed by a
non-human animal like what a waste of
life like how just what a lame ending it
would be if it was like some cheap
non-human got me like this all this hell
I was thinking like a bear human yeah
like people are just killed by an animal
yeah like a wolf or like a tiger like
how much
how much hatred like we've been so
desensitized from people getting killed
by wild animals that we don't really
fear them but like you should they don't
care yeah they don't care about you
really really should they don't have
them they don't well I don't think
people are wild animals I don't think
they they understand the horror that
could come along with like coming up on
a wolf or a bear oh I'm like terrified
that movie cocaine bear came out and
people were like yes it seems awful oh
it did yeah okay so they they were
organized people yeah they're probably
like scared of people and animals I've
been so much in the politics like oh
it's human versus human and politics all
these humans what if world war three and
all the human human and then I'm like
dude real talk like we were starting
against tigers for most of our existence
I am pretty afraid of ants did you ever
see that movie ants yeah no yeah yeah
when I was okay yeah where they're like
working in the Grasshoppers or
oppressing them no oh no no no no no A
Bug's Life this is a totally different
oh I show my Bug's Life
no no this is not an animated film it's
a scary film I remember watching it on
Cinemax no I never heard of this right
so there was a construction site and
this woman is like in her bed of course
because you have to have a naked woman
in Bed on Cinemax and she's like in her
bed and suddenly there's ants coming in
and the Ants swarm her and eat her alive
this is ants it happened at Lakewood
Manor I don't know what it was called it
was on Cinemax I was eight years old I
have no real idea I just remember this
and I remember the I remember the
visuals I remember the lighting it had
that sort of like 70s American Cinema
yellow you know that like yellow oh yeah
yeah it looked like that news you can
use the brown and she was like
ants and also being swarmed by bees like
being stung to death would just be
awesome wasps
these are good people like so we have a
cherry tree and when it block when it
when it comes into bloom or whatever
it's a uh what is it it's a I don't know
yeah it's cherry tree so does a cherry
blossom it's crazy and then it's you can
hear loud buzzing there's so many bees
B's got no beef you walk right past him
you can like wave and they're like yo
what up yeah it's the WASP that chase
you down no they're mean those are mean
excuse me I don't know if they
really are me I don't get them I get the
vibe that they're more turn it off
they're inquisitive they'll fly down
right in front of your face really
aggressively and stare at you and then
they'll fly off yeah and if you freak
out then they might freak out but
they're like aggressively patrolling no
I got stung over the summer by like a
hornet or a yellow jacket or something
on my finger and it started to swell it
took like 24 hours and then it was so
itchy but if you itch it it then as I
learned goes down the rest of your hand
and I it it I can't imagine if you had
like a thousand of them descend on you
and then you're in pain but also you
begin to itch and itching only makes it
worse it seems like a nightmare what did
you do to treat it baking soda like
water chamomile oh okay my mind not
chamomile uh and then I just tried to
not scratch it I wore gloves several
days what's that never mind Calamine
thank you I don't know what I'm talking
about nobody I was like I was like
thinking like oh did you just brew a
bunch of tunes
and I was thinking like this is some
sort of picture the rural home remedy
from Santa Clara the Bears in my yard
told me about it that's what I was
thinking and then she brewed some
dandelion tea and the colors were
amazing I wish no that wasn't it uh I
will say I think it depends on where you
live because I think when you're saying
like if you live in a city and you're
not interact with animals maybe you
don't think about them but if you live
in a rural area and you hike a lot the
first question I get all the time is
what happens if we run into a bear and
that's a legitimate question in a lot of
areas uh the same thing with do you
bring like a shotgun or something like
what do you I do nothing I go unprepared
but I know I like to hike with people
who will bring will go armed another
reason we should support the two-way
guys they're always the first people to
think I will come with a gun just in
case uh or somebody else pardon okay
there's a really good shot
can you imagine
I would love to hike with a two-way
person who can shoot down Owasso we got
these amazing water guns this summer and
they basically shoot water like it's
buck shot
yeah sprays water but it doesn't spray
it like it like turns every little
droplet into like a bead does it hurt
yes oh wow so when you get shot with it
you're like ah and then even once you're
soaked you don't want to get shot with
it because it hurts water is a drill
yeah it's like one of the the best
drills known to man yeah the water
pressure yeah you can cut I watch
almonds just look at the Grand Canyon
high pressure water watch those videos
on Instagram where they like they put a
screwdriver and then the water slices
the screwdriver in half no way metal and
everything crazy yeah
coming out of a river the other day did
you see that it was like it was like
some stupid Instagram thing you know but
it was like a water spout did you see it
was like some Russian River it was like
flooding and stuff and yeah and it just
like went up into the sky yeah there's a
thing that happens uh over the Great
Lakes when there's like a tornado it
sucks the water up and then drops it or
something like this do it like a big
splash like like a 12-foot wave will
like slam over the wow over the highway
or whatever that's cool yeah it's like a
mini tsunami unless you're on the
highway then it's very bad I mean not
really you get splashed by water and
you're like wow that was crazy it's an
interesting real life Disney ride yeah
like a water spout forms I could be
wrong about this this is what I I'm
growing up in Chicago so they say
because you're driving on Lake Shore
Drive you get really close to the water
sometimes and uh if there's like a water
spout somewhere it can pull water back
and then drop it or something like that
I don't know is it just like a water
tornado yeah and it pulls water up or
something like it sucks it up
you know and then that sounds kind of
cool yeah that's not cool weather
science is crazy well that's why we need
guns just to protect ourselves from wild
animals that was my I think we need guns
to protect ourselves from the weather
climate change right we need lasers to
defend against wasps and raindrops
actually a good laser might actually
protect you from uh a wasp like a an
array of lasers that could shoot like
nine beams at once that has Auto
tracking and targeting now we're like
doctors I mean they have those lasers
that can light a match at or pop a
balloon I imagine if you pointed that at
a a bug the bug would not be very happy
no yeah yeah I mean you can also just
use like ax body spray in a lighter but
you know no that's that you can't
control that well enough with the laser
you just point it and then the bug might
just fall off like a wall but the ax
body spray makes it is more fun and
terrifying when you're up yeah but very
dangerous okay yes don't do it this is
big too because there's like uh with all
the wildfires that have been happening
all over the place it's really it's
really crazy it rains at Burning Man it
was it was it was flooding in Vegas a
couple times and then out here we
haven't gotten rain in a minute it
rained last night for like the first
time in a while uh and then but we went
through a couple weeks like without any
rain we got hit them I think Friday yeah
we got we got told that it was really
dry and so there was a high risk of
fires but now we're gonna get a ton of
storms because of all the Hurricanes
coming up I think the the Storm at
Burning Man which no one predicted is
just God testing the pagans I think that
he's like how how much do you like
testing I think a lot of people believe
that like truly believe I fundamentally
I was talking about this with Liz
wheeler last week I think that uh he's
not happy with them and he thinks you
know if you guys are gonna put up what
was it the chapel of Babble at the
beginning we'll just say they also put
up like a big like a big uh you know
praise Ukraine thing God's unhappy about
it that's all I have to say what's
amazing is that they're they're Pagan
peace loving War mongers it's there's
something about being enlightened and
then going to be enlightened with other
people that are enlightened as opposed
to going somewhere completely
unenlightened just going somewhere to
seek Enlightenment and I think a lot of
people are going to burning man because
they want to become enlightened not
because they are I think they want to be
able to say they went for burning man
they want to seem cool but they are
actually not interested I mean everyone
has been douchey since the 90s I don't
want to speak like ubiquitously there
are probably some people there who are
seeking Enlightenment whatever else but
I think the majority of people are going
it's it is you know the Coachella of you
know non-musical Gathering I could see
how God would Smite that people yeah if
that's what I'm saying I think he was
unhappy I don't think he's smitting it I
just think he's like let's see how
committed you are this bit team and the
Jeep stuck in the mud that can never get
out because it turns to concrete she's
gonna be like an auto grave right
graveyard Cadillac Ranch out and I think
it's near Amarillo Texas have you gone a
bunch of times I've been once once in
2008 yeah how was it it was awesome yeah
I took mushrooms for like seven days
straight we had a big bag of camp and
I'd just walk around and every time
they'd start the the high would start to
change I'd come back and eat some more
and keep walking and it was start your
day like three in the afternoon because
the sunlight you want to kind of miss
the sun and then you're up till like 7
A.M every day it's it's an all night
party just blasting music and lights not
this year psychedelics and God said no
nope take a bike you just drop it on the
ground and keep walking find another
bike pick it up and use it it's it's
cool it's terrible it's it's cool if
you're single and you want to take a lot
of psychedelics that's about it I'd just
be pissed if somebody kept stealing my
bike
yeah there's no stealing everything you
take there is going to be taken that's
terrible so don't take your phone it'll
probably gonna take it might it might
get sand damage too so you're gonna
watch out for sand damage on any
equipment you're taking and you got to
wear masks right because all the Alkali
dust yeah yeah but like good sealant
masks because the dust you'll get these
white out storms will kick on and you
won't be able to see further than like
three feet in front of yourself it
really sounds like pure hell yeah it's
all about psychedelics maybe people go
and don't do psychedelics and they're
just like it's the experience
rich people with private planes who fly
in and bring have RVs deliver then put
up stages and they're like cool like
dude do it somewhere else climate
protesters Extinction Rebellion went out
there stopping up traffic people don't
realize they literally have like an
airport there like they land planes
outside there and then they go into like
this own little hermetically sealed tent
it's not like it's not what everyone
thinks it is it's like super glamping
yeah it literally is literally dude
you'll be walking and it'll be like just
desert black like dust and dark and then
there will be a building and you're like
what the is this and you walk up to
it like a bunch of walk in and it's like
a bar fully set up like I wonder if one
was a vampire bar they had vials of
blood around their neck they were like
grinding on the stage they had filed
their teeth and they were taking
people's weapons why did God not Smite
this suit it was like dark and red it
was like smoky in there like what does
this exists and everyone had they had to
give their weapons if anyone had like a
character was carrying I don't think I
don't know what kind of weapons and then
would other people just pick them up and
keep moving just like with the bike oh I
didn't see what happened but I had a
flashlight on me a really bright one and
they didn't take it and I felt like a
Jedi like my they didn't see my
lightsaber as a weapon because if if it
hit the fan I had something to blind
people within the dark I felt like I was
like armed yeah I felt it was kind of
cool feeling yeah especially when you
have people who are filing their teeth
and drinking blood it was nuts people
like that really exist yeah well you
know you know that's like part of the
there's like this um
where is it in Africa and they have this
like the big Salt Flats and everything
and people like mine salt and their
teeth get really soft and if they can
file them down
okay that's wild teeth freaked me out
I'm sorry I got a dance appointment
tomorrow yeah this actually hasn't been
bad at all I was avoiding it for years
and years because the pain and now I'm
like dude it's pain is temporal thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time